When I received this mask,
when I was invited by the Magic Knight,
I decided to dedicate
my
badagrimoire to Yunews.  Oh my
god, I'm so embarrassed all of a sudden, so I'm fine.I've
risen to the position of the leader of the Magic Knights.I've
chosen talented members guided by my own mana
and created Golden Dawn.It's about creating the
strongest stage.  You say that you want to repay Lord Julius, who became the court,
and if that
's the case, it's for the sake of another important person of
mine.
Two people who want the way
Julius Sam and his Tom are both important people
I can't choose between them
So I
can't help but laugh I have a
scar
Revealing Mysterious Eyes of the Midnight
Sun I
didn't want you to be a Japanese
[music]